let's try Bert from Jersey Bert are you
able to get right into your question
yes I am you hear me okay David I hear
you fine okay thank you for taking uh
here's my question
um you know you hear a lot of
trumpers and Trump people you know uh
they talk about his accomplishments the
comp the country is moving the right
direction uh you know all these
subjective things that's hard to deny
what I don't understand is
if you look at Trump's fiscal record
right yep we are eight trillion more in
debt from him from from the beginning
when he started to where he is today
right he's supposed to be his financial
genius he's supposed to be the
businessman and yet he added more debt
in four years than any U.S president
ever in that history that time period so
like there's a lot of criticism of trump
and you know Stormy Daniels all you know
like a list goes on you never hear any
criticism of his financial record so why
is that and where is it well it's so
obvious you're saying economically
economically right we are eight trillion
poor after Trump than before him yeah I
mean listen most people don't even
understand the difference between the
debt and deficit and are confused about
reducing the deficit versus reducing the
debt and and so it's honestly ignorance
is a big reason why this conversation
isn't had more you say to someone hey uh
uh Biden reduced the deficit and then
they go no but the debt has continued to
increase right Biden slowed down the
rate at which the debt is increasing
you've lost people so a lot of this
quite frankly with that particular issue
is people don't know what's going on
they don't understand that and I've
tried so many times to explain the
difference but I do think there are
easier metrics to look at stock market
GDP job creation unemployment inflation
consumer confidence
Etc
and on average all of those do better
under Democratic president so I tend to
focus there
the thing is this they're they're big
accomplishment is that oh the
financially we were the economy was
booming everyone was doing great well no
we're not we're as a result of his
policies and him and uh cutting taxes
and increasing spending we're eight
trillion poor we the the debt is higher
without a doubt but I I concede that
there were many economic indicators that
were strong under under Trump I just
don't think it had anything to do with
Trump being president if that makes
sense
but um I guess he just you never hear
people criticize about this there's no
you don't no you're right and like I
said I think a lot of people don't don't
even understand the difference
I apologize let's keep it to one thing
today because I'm up against the clock
and I gotta run okay thank you all right
there we go uh it's a good question we
should be talking more about that people
don't even get it so you're sort of like
trying to tread water with people that
are trying to pull you under it's a sad
situation let's go to a break uh we will
take calls again and I apologize I
wasn't able to get to everybody